je vais vous montrer un peu de magie
c'est la vraie chose j'aime
vraiment le processus de
manipulation des gens en ligne pour de l'argent
il n'y a pas d'outils en place
contre eux
[Musique] il
y avait un projet appelé le
programme de réécriture vidéo et c'était la première
application majeure d'un visage profond vous
pouviez prendre
une personne en train de parler dans une piste vidéo et
la synchroniser avec une piste audio différente  et
vous savez
manipuler leur visage pour donner l'impression qu'ils
parlent de l'autre
piste audio que je n'ai jamais rencontré forrest gump
je suis une petite théière courte et solide
le terme faux profond vient d'un
apprentissage en profondeur mélangé à de faux événements donc le
faux événement  est la
sortie que vous savez de ce qu'est un défaut,
puis euh
l'apprentissage en profondeur est le processus pour
trouver les algorithmes et tout ce que
vous savez combiner l'image avec la
vidéo, vous pouvez prendre une image
et l'appliquer à une vidéo de  quelqu'un
bouge son visage
ce qui se passe tic tac
de temps en temps j'aime
me traiter les équipes de langue profonde si
si cela a été utilisé à
des fins malveillantes malveillantes euh vous savez que vous pourriez utiliser une
plate-forme comme tic tac pour devenir viral et se
propager
vous savez des nouvelles assez dangereuses
[Musique]
en tant qu'humain si nous montons une vidéo de
quelqu'un et si les voix sonnent
suffisamment similaires, j'ai l'impression que l'image de
la euh vous savez que le faux profond
va en quelque sorte tromper les oreilles comme
vous le savez être comme oh hé c'est  la
voix de cette personne, je veux dire, vous savez qu'il y a de
très bons acteurs de la voix
qui peuvent presque reproduire la vraie chose,
cela apporte des contrefaçons profondes aux masses
d'une manière qui n'a pas vraiment été vue
auparavant,
je pense en étant capable de prendre comme par
exemple  comme un ancien membre de la famille décédé,
euh, prenant une de leurs photos
et en quelque sorte, vous savez
que cela pourrait être une
expérience vraiment cool pour beaucoup de gens
[Musique]
oh mon dieu
prendre un leader mondial et euh  faire un
gros faux d'eux et
fondamentalement, ils pourraient dire
ce qu'ils veulent, ils pourraient euh dire
des choses pour provoquer des troubles publics euh tu
sais dire
comme je suppose que je donne
des informations dangereuses ou dangereuses
je suppose comme des commandes euh tu sais aux
gens que tu connais  les membres de la famille peuvent être
usurpés, donc
les escroqueries peuvent également se produire de cette façon, je
dirais qu'il y a 10 ans, lorsque le texte était la
chose la plus importante, le texte et les images,
euh, ce n'était pas un problème aussi important,
mais maintenant euh, tu sais,
je me sens déjà comme  les plates-formes vidéo de forme plus courte
ont déjà un énorme
problème de désinformation et de fausses
nouvelles parce que la vidéo est tellement
convaincante que je suis sûr que les pirates vont
devenir beaucoup plus créatifs à propos de ce genre de
choses,
en particulier à l'avenir, mais je pense que la grande
technologie va être  interdire ensemble et
se concentrer sur des outils
qui peuvent aider à prévenir les contrefaçons profondes ou
au moins les attraper tout de suite et
probablement comme
fournir des étiquettes pour dire hé, comme vous
le savez, ce n'est pas bon, surtout vous savez sur
facebook instagram um
tic tac l'une de ces um applications
les entreprises de médias sociaux sont celles qui doivent se
concentrer sur la création de ces outils, je
pense qu'elles sont à l'avant-garde de tout cela,
car ce sont elles qui seraient les
plus touchées, ainsi que leurs utilisateurs